[Music]
on today's show we talk about dealing
with big t trauma and family history we
talked to a guy who's starting to act
like a child in response to his wife's
emotional abuse and he wants to know
what to do we talked to a guy who's a
great boss and he wants to be a little
bit better stay tuned
[Music]
what's up what's up this is john with
the dr john dolone show
talking about mental health
relationships
relational iq changing your life
owning what happened in the past
making changes for tomorrow for today
for today we're a few weeks into the new
year
man i hope your new resolutions are
crushing i hope you are leaning into
things you're stepping into things
you're swinging into things whatever it
looks like for you and you're making it
happen
hope your marriages are good your kids
are doing all right
if they're not stop the presses and get
that stuff under control now it's a new
year it's a new year
and good to see you kelly
thank you good to be here
benjamin
good to be here seeing your face and not
james is so good oh i missed i agree
james is just stunningly handsome
you're not so much but i like seeing you
i'm just kidding you look great that's
fair you look great you look just
fantastic and kelly i will just say you
are brilliant
and very kind
thank you very much people on the
internets don't like me telling you that
you look beautiful today
i don't mind they don't
they don't like it that's on them oh and
there's the director of hr walking out
here i see where how this thing goes
just started here and down it went let's
go to ray in
raleigh north carolina beautiful part of
the country what's up ray
uh hey how you doing we're getting it
how about you
i'm doing pretty good how about uh how
about yourself yeah well uh
we're all right we're all right if i
told you that today was just the
greatest i that would be dishonest but
you know what we're doing well the
heater and air conditioning works and my
paycheck deposited so i'm gonna count it
good we're gonna go from there
okay sounds good so what's up
well um me and my husband have suffered
some pretty big tree trauma growing up
and are still going through some stuff
now
yeah i need to know how to deal with it
oh hon
you said big t trauma right
yeah
so that's it's still sitting on you
pretty tight because it's hard to even
say it out loud tell me what's going on
okay
take your breath take your time
okay so um
uh my mom was killed when i was little
oh man
and um
i was um
messed with
when i was growing up
and um
my parents uh my stepmom and my dad were
pretty emotionally abusive
and um
they they became alcoholics
um whenever i turned 18. i think they
may have suffered that um whenever i was
growing up but i never noticed it until
i turned 18.
um
they always just kind of i was just kind
of secluded and left to myself for the
most part yes
did they know about the sexual abuse
no i've never told anyone except my
husband and my best friend gotcha okay
um
and my husband he was um raped when he
was 10 by a close family friend and
his mom was pretty sexually abusive
towards him
and um
his i mean pretty much our whole
families were pretty emotionally abusive
to us but we have like no one
and the one person we thought we had
this year to help us out was um
our grandma and his sod and it turned
out that she was just using us
so that she can regain her relationship
with her
son which is my husband's dad and
everything that we were telling her and
trying to confide in her
she was just relaying back to that to
the people that have abused us
and i've i've got three awesome
beautiful girls and an awesome husband
and
you know we've been through a lot
and it's like every pregnancy i've had
it's like they've reared their ugly
heads and showed up yes
and um we we sent uh
them letters both both as a parent um
with my parents i just told them you
know
we i've already called them and asked
them hey don't drink around the kids you
know
i know you've got an alcohol problem and
i'm i don't judge you for drinking we
don't care about that at all i just
don't want you doing it when the kids
are there
and my stepmom has ended up calling my
husband's or not calling she facebooked
my husband's mom and was like playing
that man in a booboo i get to see the
grandkids and you don't card to her
so all that was screenshot by his dad
and sent to him
so
do me a favor do you yes are you on your
cell phone
yes okay
um
take your phone and i'll just wait here
for a second and i want you to pull up
your parents
and i want you to
delete their numbers from your phone
okay
or block them i don't know the right way
to do that i just know they need to be
out where they can't contact they're
you're done
okay well i've already blocked them on
facebook and
just yeah
done
okay
and then i want you to take your in-laws
and done they're blocked they can't
contact you they can't get in touch with
you they're not welcome around you
they're not welcome around your family
yeah so that
and
okay they're done
done yes
yeah
no more no more discussions no more
trying to make this thing work no more
being responsible
for
their brutality and their evil
and their manipulation and their abuse
and their silence
no more yeah you got three little girls
that are worth more than that
you and your husband have found yourself
on the other side of hell but you you're
still chained to it and you're going to
find out those chains aren't
clasped you're holding on to those
chains i want you to let them go
okay and that's hard
but we're done
[Music]
okay
well see that that's the problem i'm
having me and my husband are a little
out of disconnect with that okay that's
fine um that's fine uh
here here's here's what here's the the
things you just laid out to me i bet
your aces score is a seven or eight if
not
more
uh i want you to get online today in
aces a-c-e-s it's the adverse childhood
experiences scale
um i want you to just take it it's
online it's ten questions
and
if you score over a four which you have
you're more likely to get cancer strokes
heart attacks all
your body is at war
yes right yeah yep and
the goal of healing from big t trauma is
this trauma simply means your body is
responding in the present to things that
happen in the past as though it's
happening again right now
yeah
and if you were sexually abused as a
child as you have daughters that get
within shouting distance of that age
your body remembers that story
yes and it starts sounding every alarm
because it's danger danger danger
yep and
it's not a matter if you don't trust
them it's that your body doesn't trust
the world
and more importantly your body doesn't
trust relationships
and that's that weird thing is you gotta
you gotta have relationships or we die
literally exactly yeah i finally was
able to make one
awesome friend um i worked with her and
i've got one we've got one person in our
life that we can trust awesome awesome
so
the goal is is to
work through the big t trauma so that
you can think about what happened
you can remember those conversations
a on your own terms and b your body
doesn't take off on you because it knows
it's safe now
that's the goal right right can't undo
that stuff we got to own it it happened
and then the question is now what right
um yes
first
the first thing the first order of
business is cutting ties with the people
who abuse you
yes and your language in this case
matters
um
how did you how did your mom how was she
killed
an ex-boyfriend
shot her at a gas station okay so
they're killed is
is
the word is your mom passed away she
died
but yes the way you told that to me
could have been a car wreck
could have been a medical issue your mom
was murdered
yes and you have to own that language
you were not messed with as a kid
you were sexually abused
yeah
and when you come up with in this and i
do it we all do it we when we use
language to take the sting off of what
happened to us in our present in our
past
some you know sometimes people say like
well my husband just was you know
he cheated on you right you got to say
it out loud
yeah your body feels the weight of it
but your mind has new words
and you know what happens when you lay
old new flooring over old flooring and
there's water there mold grows
underneath it just rots out everything
yeah and so we got to use the words of
what actually happened
and then we have to respond to that
stuff okay
yeah your parents were
abusive they were alcoholic they were
absent
trauma can also be so you told me some
big t traumas you you probably know this
big t trauma can also be what didn't
happen
yeah moms and dads are supposed to be
present with their kids and let them
know that they're safe and that they are
loved
and yeah children of alcoholics don't
get that
that's correct yeah right
so
the goal here is to experience
those to think about those things and
your body doesn't take off on you you're
able to just be present with your
husband with your daughters sounds like
your husband still wants to stay
connected to them
yeah okay um he well he wants
he wants to separate us from it but he
thinks that he can be this big wall that
separates but i don't want him to be the
wall because it's just like letting the
stupid bear in the living room maul my
husband so that he doesn't get to us i
think there needs to be a separation
from all of it absolutely yes so
your husband is
trying to be a good kid and as somebody
who grew up like he did he was probably
responsible
for the
emotional and psychological and
relational well-being of the adults in
his life
well can i tell you what happened this
weekend absolutely yeah
is uh we told them in a letter that we
were not talking to his mother period
and we were having no contact with her
and we were just completely and totally
done with her and we needed to go seek
counsel on how to handle his dad
because that's where we weren't
agreeing on how to handle it i just
wanted to cut him off just like his mom
um
and he doesn't see it that way yet
because he was closer to his dad and his
eyes than anyone else well anyway
his dad called him the other day or
messaged him and said that he wanted to
meet with a man to man like degrading my
husband are we gonna are we gonna fight
okay i don't know that's what it sounded
like to me but anyway he met with him at
a park and he brought his favorite
freaking cookies that his mom gave him
um
it's like i guess a peace offering or
whatever and tried to talk things or he
wanted to talk things out but my husband
wasn't giving him any information or
anything just
that we weren't going to be talking to
mom pretty much and um
his dad told him he he asked him you
know if the stuff that your mom did
bothered you why didn't you say anything
about it and it made me stick and oh
yeah dude don't that crap because now oh
it's your husband's fault now
yeah exactly
stupid you know whose fault it is
i'm gonna go down that road here's the
deal dad knew that crap was going on
yes absolutely
and it's not just the dad the grandma
has
she called the hospital when i was
giving birth to my third daughter in
september
she showed up to our house the week
after i had my baby um not invited
unannounced my oldest daughter was
crying because she couldn't understand
why she couldn't go see grandma
and i had to explain to her honey we're
not talking to grandma right now i don't
know how to explain this to you right
now but when i know i will tell you one
day not right now
and
then my husband got her to leave and
then she told him that she was going to
call his dad and then showed up the next
day uninvited
luckily this time i saw them so i was
able to get the kids in the back room so
that my husband could go handle them
outside
but they showed up with his mom his dad
and his grandma they all came back and
um i just want to call the cops
absolutely have them deal with them
absolutely this is manipulative
narcissist nonsense
exactly and his his grandma showed up at
his place of work last night
and um
yeah so grandma needs to be notified
that there's going to be a restraining
order against her if she shows up again
okay
okay should we even have a talk with her
because i don't think we should at this
point
at some point surely your husband has
said you're not welcome here i'd like
you to go
well he did at the at the um whenever
she showed up at our house but now he
we agreed that we would have a
conversation with her but i don't even
think there needs to be a conversation
anymore i would not have one in person i
would make a phone call i would okay and
i would say
you are not welcome in my house you are
no longer a part of our life
i would recommend and ray and i know
this is hard i'd recommend y'all think
about what the next 18 months 12 months
24 months looks like for y'all to move
and go somewhere these these roads haunt
you
yes i want i've been wanting to move so
bad it's time it's time and here's
here's the thing
it's time for you to sit down and tell
your husband what's actually happening
and here's what i you can tell me i'm
wrong
but children who grew up in systems of
abuse which is how you grew up and your
husband did too
they get really good at two things
making sure everybody around them is
okay
and keeping secrets
yup and you all have an ecosystem in
your home where both of you are trying
to make sure the other one's okay
you're trying to keep up a fantasy where
these kids that you have these beautiful
daughters that you have are still gonna
have grandparents
and y'all keep secrets from each other
well
not really um
we
we tell each other everything even when
it hurts does he know
that you're about done
because you are absolutely okay he gets
it yes
yes all right so here's supported me
calling today i think he just needs to
hear it from somebody else good because
he's about to lose you
yeah
yeah i'm getting pretty resentful yes
there you go and he may not lose you in
spirit i mean a body but he's gonna lose
you in spirit
yeah and then you know what happens this
whole cycle starts over again
yeah
because the only way to get over the gap
of being married to someone who you love
but you chose abusers over them the only
way to get through that is disconnecting
whether it's alcohol or whether it's
working too much or whether it's
somebody what
here it goes again and your daughters
grow up in a house with two people who
are absent and
they're there in body but they're not
there in spirit and the whole thing
happens again
yep right
you and your husband are doing brave
things you're still like terry reel says
you're staring down this forest fire
and saying the generational trauma stops
with us
yep but what i'm telling you is you
gotta go all the way
okay you can't steer this forest fire
down and one of you's got a hose and the
other person's just being like hey don't
spray so hard don't spray that water too
fast you're gonna then you're gonna both
you're everybody's gonna burn
how like
i i just made a friend
and i'm afraid i'll lose her if i move
you
listen
right now you're s
let's worry about things in order okay
okay
let's worry about things in order
you might have a different relationship
you might have to go make new friends
here's what you've proven to yourself
that you're worth being loved and you're
worth hanging out with yeah and you're
worth having joy and there are good
people a whole whole bunch of them that
are trustworthy you can tell crazy
things too and then we'll laugh and say
hey i'll buy beers or you found that
person it exists
yeah and so i want you to know that
there's a bunch of hers out there
now am i telling you you got to break up
with your friend and all that kind of
stuff i'm telling you this first you got
to get safe and you're not safe
yes
first second you got to get on the same
page with your husband
you all got to get on the same page with
a game plan
and at some point it comes to you saying
we are moving you can be a part of this
conversation but i can't be around this
evil any more
okay
the fantasy that you're gonna hold this
family together that grandparents are
gonna come around it's over
right
and you've if you've ever listened we've
done over 200 something shows of this
show i've never watched all of them
yeah you're the only one i i've never
told somebody
to get their phone out and disconnect
from their parents forever and i'm
telling you that
right right because they've got their
foot on your head and you underwater and
you can't breathe
and it's time yes
it's time
okay
let that
go yeah that feels really good to hear
you and your husband i want you to go
meet with somebody together if you can
okay if you can't afford it sell
something
i'd rather you sit on folding lawn
chairs in your living room than have a
couch but make sure that you and your
husband have gotten six sessions of
trauma counseling together cause y'all
got a lot of healing and you don't want
to pass this on
right i mean we've yeah so here's what i
i don't know if y'all have done this
maybe you have maybe you have it
i want you guys
you've heard me say this a thousand
times and you're getting it too have you
ever gone to
somewhere and just said what could it be
like
usually in people in your position
you're trying to always putting out the
next fire the next fire in the next fire
you never get to sit down and dream what
would it look like there was just no
fires
well actually we we started this whole
healing process like five years ago when
we started like watching the dave ramsey
stuff and we just got out of debt and
paid off our house at the beginning of
this year wow
congrats
thank you i appreciate that
everybody that's when we started
noticing the or i guess figuring out
that our family we're not going to be
able to be a part of their lives yes
once they saw that we were doing better
it brings the leeches out yes yes
the vampires come out so
you may have to sell that paid for house
and go pay for another house with cash
in another city
yeah
yeah i know it's hard i know it's hard
but you live around vampires and at some
point they're gonna one of them is gonna
get their teeth in your kids
exactly yeah that's the scary part one
of their kids cousins sisters roommates
brothers gonna be it's just gonna go on
and on and on
uh here let's do this in order though
moving is not a conversation for today
conversation for today is we start
by getting evil out of my house
i will not allow people to abuse me or
my family or manipulate us anymore
starts with a phone call to all the
parents to grandma this is the last
phone call
we are disconnecting from you
if you come to our house unannounced we
will call the police
if you show up to my kid's school we
will call the police
we are done
and that will be hard and you'll have to
grieve that with your husband that'll be
hard and then you begin making plans for
what is next
but you're worth a life where you're not
abused anymore
you're worth a life where your daughters
are safe
and you're worth a life of laughter
and joy and really hard work
in the gym at your career at whatever
your hobbies are
[Music]
you're with more i'm sorry that this
these the carts you were dealt right
you've played them incredibly you have
played them in
credibly
and now it's time to get up from that
table go to the table
you outgrown that table
you're an absolute brave rock star
keep us in the loop over the next few
months and we'll walk alongside you it's
grateful i'm grateful to have gotten to
talk to you today you're a brave brave
soul we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we're back let's go to my
hometown h2o and talk to fred what's up
fred how we doing
hey doing good thanks for talking to me
that's real exciting you got it brother
it's exciting for me too what's up
well um i'll try to be a coherent here
um
you're on the wrong show if you want to
be killed right yeah wrong [ __ ] anyway
yeah by uh anyway my relationship with
my spouse has kind of
it's devolved into
basically what i feel is abuse and you
know emotional and you know
mental abuse and i started reacting by
lashing out physically and not at her
but you know at our house and i'll punch
holes and things and
throw objects and why do you do that
that's a it seems like a strange choice
why do you choose that right i i don't
know it's a i guess it's a it's a poor
way of
i feel like if i don't hit something
else i'm going to hit someone i guess
that's a false choice
i suppose so yeah it is absolutely false
from this point who who taught you that
did your old man do that did your mom do
that no no my my dad was the calmest
person on the planet my mom was very
very you know she was physically and
verbally abusive but she never she never
punched holes in anything but
um so here's the deal i don't know
never again
got it
yes uh-huh
say it
never again will i
lash out physically at anyone or
anything done we're good
yeah i hope so yeah every time you're
about to hit a wall here's what i want
you to think
hey mom
i got your anger
and your rage
and i am gonna show you how tough i am
even though it's gonna cost me my
marriage i want you just to think that
before you hit something
okay okay
yeah
cool
all right so that is not even why you
called but
um
or here's here's a simpler way right
before you hit something ask yourself
why am i choosing to hit this
because if you can choose to hit it then
you can choose not to
yeah that's absolutely right right like
why am i choosing i do that all the time
dude like why am i choosing to tail this
guy who just cut me off what what a dumb
why am i choosing to eat this i know
it's not gonna make me feel good like
what am i doing i mean so i'm i'm i'm
there with you but when i start
when i take ownership
of what's happening and i use ownership
language in my relationships things
change my behaviors change all right so
your marriage is devolving you've got a
an emotionally abusive wife
you're choosing to act like a
five-year-old and then what
well
i guess
i feel like we're both kind of at that
point where
it feels like it feels like
the marriage and the family is slipping
out of our hands are you done no no no
no they don't slip out of your hands
you're letting them go
are y'all are you done
yeah i don't want to be no certainly not
i absolutely love my wife and i love my
family and you know you got little ones
too
oh yeah yeah we got a two-year-old and a
nine-month-old um
and then she's got a stepson or i've got
a step-son that's from her previous
marriage who is six
um they're they're awesome um
hey
again
we'll get to why you called eventually i
don't even know why you called yeah i
keep interrupting you
that stuff i said earlier about not ever
hitting anything ever again you got
little kids in the house brother
no i never never again
got it
oh absolutely do not pass this on to
them
don't teach them that this is the way
grown-ups handle their frustration
they deserve better than that fair
yeah absolutely cool and i would tell
the same thing to your wife don't
emotionally abuse your husband don't
yell and scream and say mean things to
people
ever you're not worth that she's worth
more than that but also don't
demonstrate to kids this is what adult
relationships look like because then
they take that crap to school with them
and then so goes our country right okay
so why don't you call man i keep
interrupting you well no
honestly i don't know if i if i know why
i just i i i'm so lost i don't know what
to do does your wife want a divorce
no i don't i don't think so
she brings up well let's just divorce
them all the time and you know when
there's a fight
so it sounds like she might want to get
divorced
well i i
she says a lot of stuff and and i don't
know i mean i think so is she is she a
liar she's not trustworthy
uh
uh well i mean
sounds like she's being really clear
with you
let's just get a divorce then maybe a
hint that she wants to get a divorce
is it that you don't want to see that
come to fruition
oh man i definitely don't and then maybe
that's maybe i just have blinders on i
just i feel like in my heart she doesn't
because
once we once we finally screw our heads
on tight and actually talk to each other
like adults
we're able to
say wow i was so stupid and i'm so sorry
and
let's not do this again but then it
happens again
and i don't know how to break out of
this cycle and i certainly hope she
doesn't want a divorce um i maybe she
does but i i definitely i don't want to
lose her i don't want to lose that time
with my kids it's so precious to me um
here's here's what i
um there's very real moments
involving yelling
involving emotional abuse involving
physical abuse
when i would recommend a 30-day
separation everybody's got it someone's
gotta go get an apartment get a hotel
and we gotta let everything calm down
because the volatility in your marriage
the volatility with your kids it creates
a cyclone that is almost impossible to
get out of until there's some sort of
physical
break
yeah
and i don't want a i'm not telling you
get divorced i'm saying somebody's gotta
step out and say i'm gonna let this
thing breathe for a second
because this this dynamic this dance has
to stop
right
okay
somebody's gotta turn the lights on and
say what are we doing and you can't keep
dancing like this and then apologizing
and dancing again because the apologies
don't mean anything anymore
yeah
and you've got an abusive household and
you've got three kids in it not gonna do
that
have you all gone to see a marriage
counselor
yeah we're actually seeing one right now
and she is absolutely amazing um
we're seeing her tomorrow like you know
maybe it's the type of thing where
things get will get worse before they
get better i don't know but it's just uh
you know
um
so what is she recommending
well she's not really recommending
anything she's we're just she's
we've been like the three sessions or
something
she's just recommending we identify the
identify what these
what is the core emotion i guess eft i
don't know if you're familiar but yes i
am so
back up all of that before you start
digging into core emotions and pass but
say i will never talk to you that way
ever again
i will never punch a hole through wall
ever again
you have to stop abusive behaviors
before you start getting into core
issues and feelings and all that crap
yeah okay
you have to stop the abuse
right because here's why you can't get
into core issues if you haven't dealt
with the
abusive behavior because the core issue
is what sets off the abuse of behavior
so reverse engineer it
yeah
stop setting fires and then figure out
why do i always want to set fires
and so the whole thing starts with a
contract and
um
i've got several colleagues across the
country that do this all the time
relational contracts
i agree to never cuss at you again to
raise my voice at you again and if i
feel like it's about to happen instead
of choosing to raise my voice at you i
will choose to go for a walk and you
will let me go and then when i come back
i will choose to engage in a
conversation with you and the choice
language is important because we feel
like i just couldn't help it bullcrap we
can
we can and if we can't help it in the
moment we can help it five minutes
before if we came up at five minutes
before we can help it ten minutes before
an hour before two hours before
yeah
right
yeah it's like people who drink coffee
at eight
eight pm at dinner and then they have to
take you know some kind of crazy
medicine to go to sleep at night
right the inability to sleep started
with choices made a long time ago so you
have a contract that you all signed to
say i will not hit another thing
because right now your wife doesn't feel
safe and you don't feel safe right right
oh yeah and we've we've said as much to
each other
so there's a lot of i don't feel safe
and yeah
we're struggling so much to get to that
safe point we had points where we felt
safe i just don't know how to get back
there here's how you say what does safe
look like
safe is you don't yell at me
because when you yell at me it reminds
me of my mom ever my five-year-old
little boy comes out to protect me
and then i act like a five-year-old by
throwing things and hitting things and
saying things that i wish i hadn't said
and she says whenever you don't do
whatever or you're not whatever
i lash out because i learned that some i
saw that
behavior modeled through some system i
was a part of
and i turn into a seven year old and act
like a seven-year-old doing a temper
tantrum
i won't do that anymore and when i feel
it coming i will call it out
it's gonna sound so cheesy bro you gotta
practice
you gotta practice okay yeah if you've
ever been like in like whenever i do was
do it in mma we do kickboxing sparring
there's always one idiot when
everybody's sparring everybody's going
70 there's always one idiot going 110.
and it always causes problems and it
turns into a whole thing there's always
one [ __ ] in the gym doing that
and yeah
we have to say we are going to practice
i'm not going to go 110
when i feel myself leaning into these
things that we're going to agree what
safety is in my how in our house we're
going to agree with safety looks like
and then we're going to practice it
and then when everybody feels safe
then you can do
sophisticated things like dealing with
core issues
and dealing with feelings and dealing
with past trauma then you can own your
story but until you
are safe man you can't own nothing
because your body's just trying to
survive
is that right
oh yeah man yeah that is resonating with
me uh big time so here's the here's your
steps okay
i want you to take your wife out and say
we're going to have a like a good
conversation together no fights no
nothing
like let's have a good talk
and then i want you to take a piece of
paper or a fancy notebook whatever you
want and say
i want us to talk about what does it
feel like
to be safe what does safe look like for
us paint a picture of it man crystal
clear
safe doesn't look and it's not gonna be
like when you do this i don't feel safe
nope yeah that's how it goes right no no
what a safe looks like you and me
sitting on the couch just watching tv
safe looks like you and me going to the
gym together safe looks like you and me
going out to dinner we got babysitter
for the three kids
and then let's make that happen well
then how do we feel good sitting on the
couch together well the house is picked
up and you always drop your crap
everywhere or that you help with you
help with bed bedtime with the kids
and then i can relax finally that's how
you reverse engineer these things you
start with a picture and then you work
backwards
okay
all right
and then i want you to take this
agreement to your counselor and say hey
we did some work on our own
and we agreed
we're going to stop these behaviors that
make the other person feel unsafe we're
going to practice them
and then the counselor is going to be
like oh my gosh i'm a great counselor
and you can be like nope i called some
idiot on the radio for free
thanks and then you can do the hard
trauma work and i'm not dismissing
feeling work it's important i'm not
dismissing core issue work that stuff's
all good but you can't address those
things in the middle of a fire
yeah it's like trying to decide like why
it's so hot and you're
and you're standing in the middle of an
inferno get out of the fire first and
then we can have the cool philosophical
physics discussions or whatever you know
okay
hey can i tell you something brother
yeah you're worth not being angry all
the time
life is super cool when you're not angry
all the time
it's just that's just peaceful man you
just laugh
or when you're sad you just get to be
sad but you don't be sad and get raged
and kids you got a six or four or
two-year-old
yeah
or sorry a six a six a two and a um not
an told that's right so i don't know how
to say this in a nice way but the season
you're in right now sucks
it's hard
yeah
it's super fun man i love hugging babies
and i met i got a five-year-old i love
it love it love it
and there's a lot of diapers and a lot
of crying and a lot of can i have a
snack can i have a snack and not very
much sex and connection and intimacy
a lot of exhaustion
am i ringing a bell
oh my gosh yeah yes
so you're also in the middle of winter
and you found yourself out in the front
yard with no jacket it's just cold it
sucks right now spring's coming
go get a jacket on man go be safe in
this season okay
okay
can you do that well yeah
yeah i think so um i no
no
can you do that
i absolutely can yes you can you can do
whatever you want to you're from houston
man
cali you can bang on trash cans for all
i care that was an astros joke hope that
was good dude you can do whatever you
want man
you can you can you can you gotta own
your past you've done this crap and now
you gotta say okay now what now what's
next
what's it gonna look like what's the
future gonna look like we get to decide
we're going to start with being safe
then we're going to go from there
same team we're good
yeah 100 okay so here's the thing oh
yeah i want you i want you to holler at
me after you take your wife out and i
want you to go to a nice place
go to somewhere nice
take your wife out somewhere nice have
this safety conversation
and if it gets hot if she starts it say
no no
no no fights no fights
and if she wants to fight say okay cool
let's we're gonna do this another time
let's just enjoy your dinner
and we'll talk about what's a picture of
safety look like and let's reverse
engineer it and if she points out things
about you that you're falling short just
take it
own it
don't fight it own it
and then bring that stuff to your
counselor keep working keep working
you're in the right path keep working
and don't forget you're in a crappy
season
it's a lot of little kids man it does
get better
be brave my brother we'll be right back
on the doctor john dolone's show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumer access dot org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane sweet
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take one more let's go
out to
california and talk to steven in orange
california what's up brother stephen how
are we doing
hey good morning dr john doing good how
are you outstanding my man what's up
cool so i had a question about someone
on my team
i run a small marketing company and we
have a really supportive vulture like
amazing super young guys
um and i have one team member who's
starting some new medication
for her increasingly manic and
depressive episodes
so i'm curious how do i as a leader and
we as a team be there for her while
still providing accountability for her
for her performance so that way she can
grow into like a respected leader as
opposed to just a special case yeah dude
man what a stun
jeez
every time i think the world's like
going sideways i talk to somebody like
you who totally restores my faith in
humanity people who want to do right and
love right and honor right and make a
living
and make good money and provide good for
you man like for real what a stud thank
you so you say you've got a supportive
culture what does that mean
so you know i i got this group of kids
and i i don't mean that to be derogatory
like i'm i'm 27 and almost 28 so
obviously i'm not super old but
[Music]
like all of my guys are
barely out of high school college age
like young okay and so when i say
supportive culture like
they're they all hang out together they
all check in on each other we we
primarily focus on on uh face-to-face
sales
so if somebody had a rough day didn't
close
someone will get like seven text
messages hey how was your day what
happened
um we all know about each other's family
we all know it like we spend christmas
parties together like like close
so
as of right now it's not super public
information um of what she's going
through but
it will come out and it's noticeable
behavior-wise
they will want to be there for her
gotcha
so
here's a common thing that happens in
situations like yours
um young guy you're still a young guy
has a business and i'm assuming it's
working is that fair
yeah like you're doing good um you start
hiring some employees and dude you love
employees they're coming to put food on
your table you're putting food on their
table
you hire people especially when the
company's small that are super cool like
you like them they're kind of like you
and you all get along or you value
diversity and you hire people that are
way different than you but the fact that
you hire people way different from you
makes them kind of like you right it's
just a cool gang
and everything is magic until somebody
has to get fired
and then it put it feels like it pokes a
hole in the balloon
because then it's like i thought we were
bros and it's like we are but i'm the
boss and i run a business and the
business goes away if we don't make
money and to make money we have to have
a set of agreed-upon values and
operating rules and et cetera et cetera
et cetera right have you had those have
you ever had to fire anybody yet
oh yeah yeah no i've been open
steve was like
fire maul it's awesome okay so you've
been there
yeah and we're we're we're real clear
about standards and performance metrics
and expectations fantastic okay so
here's here's the thing
businesses uh have over the last 15 25
years have gotten into appropriately so
caring and caring has really been
lasered on you know
health care in some places spiritual
care in some places and
obviously recently it's been in mental
health care
because our country's falling apart
people are anxious and depressed and
spinning out and ocd and 88 sheet and
every other whatever whatever diagnostic
you can throw at people
and
the best care you can give somebody in
this situation is to point them to a
professional resource and have strong
behavior standards a strong
performance standards for their job
remember this phrase it's a context not
an excuse
okay here's what that here's what that
means
they have to get their job done
the goal post is where the goal post is
that's how far that kick is going to be
what support looks like is sometimes
people can get things done in three days
when they're on a manic
episode that takes other people four
weeks
that's the magic of somebody with
bipolar they really are that good when
they're when they're up
oh yeah and they disappear for weeks at
a time too or they show up in spirit but
it is not a not a pretty sight
you experienced that
oh yeah and
to her credit like when she's up she is
the top performer
yeah dude dude there's i got several
friends with bipolar they're the best
the
the best
until yeah until until they're in a
tough cycle and i want to i love my
friends i want to honor my friends
like i walk alongside them i mean i i
love them love them love them
if they're going to work for me you
still got to be at work or
you still have to get your work done
or you still have to get this stuff in
on time you cannot steal
so those standards have to hold
and what often happens is we want to
have a whole bunch of conversations
and you get into hipaa stuff and you get
into ada stuff you get into
discrimination because well hey we're
going to give her a little bit more time
because of this we're going to take away
we're going to loosen the standards here
but not over here and you just create a
mess for yourself
and so if you're in a business where if
you can get your work done at home great
or if you want to come in great or you
got to put one day of work in in the
office great or it's a five-day you got
to be here every day
whatever your environment or culture is
that adapts to the job but it's about
the job performance not about well you
know
she's got
right because this is bipolar this one's
tough this one's for real this is legit
and
good then it goes to the next one
then it goes to a little bit less one
and then it goes to well i've got adhd
so i don't come in on tuesdays and then
it goes to another one and it goes to
i've got ocd so i can't work on this
type of computer then
where does it go
you hear what i'm saying
ultimately you're a good good man
like i'm glad to know people like you
are doing business i think you love her
by saying your responsibility is to get
the care you need we will let you off
for
counseling
i'll help you pay for it i don't know
what your what your employee benefit
structure is but i'll help you pay for
it
i will contribute money too i will help
you with medication um
i'm not gonna be the guy who's counsel's
you
we're not gonna do a bunch of seven-hour
conversations um every two weeks about
how things are going and i need you to
step up we're not going to do that
because for a person with bipolar that
ends up becoming worse it becomes some
like a form of torture in a way
does that freak you out scare you sounds
like you don't like that
no it's it's not that it freaks me out
on that part i'm personally speaking i'm
i'm actually pretty familiar with kind
of these cycles now that works i'm
thinking from the perspective of uh you
know some of the other guys on the team
that have never seen this before yeah
where the temptation is to have those
seven hour regular conversations because
it's an attempt to comfort
uh as opposed to actually solving
something yes and bipolar is not
something you solve it's it's it's a
healing process
yeah and so
uh
the way i handle that with across the
board my employees is to ask permission
of this person
are you okay with what level are you
okay with us sharing do you want to
share nothing you know we've got a very
tight-knit culture everybody talks
everybody wants to love each other and
support each other
um
how comfortable are you with how do you
want this narrative to go make sure she
understands she's in control of any
story that goes out that can't be yours
and
most of the time the best thing to say
is not a lot
like i'm just struggling with some
medical stuff
and i'm working on it and i'm uh boss
you know steven's being awesome and he's
hooking me up with counseling and taking
care of us and you can let your team
know hey if you're struggling with
medical stuff family stuff um
i'm not gonna be able to solve that for
you that's what professionals are for
that's what doctors are for and
therapists are for um but i wanna work
with you because i love you and i know
life happens not just in this office
life happens all over the place and i
want you to feel supported and if you
need a couple of days come let me know
if you need us to work um an alternative
schedule for you and that works in your
business let me know
um
but i'm going to keep things
confidential and i'm also going to hold
the standard i'm going to hold i'm going
to hold you accountable
right
and man i think that's the level of care
and then when it gets into the
nitty-gritty and what happened and where
were you and what about your brain
chemistry and why are you taking that
med you should be taking this man no way
jose dude that is not anybody's
responsibility except for a doctor
right and uh employers get themselves in
a lot of trouble doing that and
employees i mean some of them got to
learn the hard way
you know what i mean
like hey
that's those 14-hour conversations you
just show up to work tired
like it's not a good idea
what's a great idea is just loving her
and uh going to dinner then everybody go
home
but dude like i say i'll say it a third
time i'm glad to know you're out there
in the world
will she give you permission to tell the
staff
uh meeting like other people on the team
yeah
uh well she is um
kind of her
uh
her leadership so to speak because she
she's kind of uh third or fourth down
for me so to speak
and so kind of the whole chain already
knows
so she she approached kind of the the
necessary people
she already made contingency plans of
like hey if i'm having something happen
maybe i swapped this day for this day so
okay
she's been really proactive about that
story that's a hey that's a person you
double i mean that's the person who's
invested in her own healing that's
remarkable that's awesome yeah
it's really great um
i was gonna say if she's open to telling
people at that level then one of the
great things you can do is co-create an
accountability plan with her
how can i best hold you accountable to
these deadlines
and then she gets to speak it well it
really helps if i text you at eight
o'clock and say i can't make it tomorrow
i'm not playing i'm not screwing around
i can't make it tomorrow but i will make
you know what i mean i will make it up
here and i will figure this out there
then y'all co-create that and then
there's a plan you can hold her
accountable to that she got to speak
into
and now you're in magic your magic
territory because there's there's
there's there's dual ownership it's not
just you taking ownership of her life
but she's got some stake in it too and
it sounds like she's she's that type of
person the
that's awesome
yeah brother i'd co-create that together
i think that's fantastic and then and
she may be the first person to say i
like these seven hour meetings i like
the attention i like the connection
they're not helpful
and then you can as the boss tell
everybody hey we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna do run around um
here's how to here's how to talk to
somebody who's having medical challenges
let them bring it up you don't dig in
right so you can have some of these
humanitarian socialized socialization
conversations with your staff um but man
if she's that open
which is just uh she's a gift too what's
she's a rock star also
um
then she can be a part of here's here's
what i need in this season here's what i
definitely don't need that season that's
great thank you so much for that call
brother stephen that's awesome man golly
man kelly i wish
you were a boss like that
just kidding
you're like you're a boss like that is
that fair
do you care about us like that
i feel like you care about james
james
very much huh
i care about you all you do
do you care about ben though
yeah kelly hey back off
you're like the most caring person back
here you know who the most caring person
is james charles and
he's not here today obviously so we can
talk bad about him even though he's
probably gonna edit this and he'll hear
it all oh i edit this so i'll keep it in
oh my gosh yes
the fact that there's just over the last
year and a half the narrative cast
across the country
that james is some sort of like tyrant
he's like the sweetest kindest guy in
this building i know and everybody
thinks he's so quiet and he's you know
so to himself and he is one of the
kindest people it's awesome
it's just you that's i'm just kidding
you're kind too you're kind of lovely
who's not the kind person listen i yeah
it's all a charade i'm the me
ben am i mean i
all right
is from chris carraba
otherwise known as dashboard
confessional and you can say oh are you
serious yes this is a great song this
was a great song i remember getting all
goosebumps and whatnot back in the
earlies
off the so impossible ep this is the
acoustic version the og version
song's called hands down it goes like
this
breathe in for luck breathe in so deep
the air is blessed you share with me the
night is wild so calm and dull these
hearts they race from self-control
your legs are smooth as they graze mine
we're doing fine we're doing nothing at
all oh man my hopes are so high your
kiss might kill me
so won't you kill me so i die happy
that's a good line chris my heart is
yours to fill or burst to break or bury
or wear his jewelry
whichever you prefer
my gosh this song is so good
hands down this is the best date i can
ever remember
what a great song hey it's been fun
we'll see you soon on the dr john de
luna show